you know courage without genius might
not get you where you need to go but
genius without courage almost certainly
won't in this industry you don't have a
business until you have a product the
entrepreneur with the idea at the right
time is going to look like a genius the
algebra with the right idea the wrong
time is gonna look like a [ __ ] failure
is a wonderful thing failure teaches you
all this stuff and it's great to fail a
lot like and we don't like buy any of
that new companies generally shouldn't
exist existing companies are usually
pretty good at what they do
having the right idea and having at the
right time and being able to execute on
it is 99% of it no matter how dire it
gets no matter how like evil Moriarty is
sure like saying I have that stroke of
genius it's gonna save the day I think
that the development career path skills
training is going to be such a more
fundamental part of how the economy
works my business partner my last
company Ben Horowitz kind of attorney
calls the the law crappy people you've
been sitting here listening to me for 20
minutes and I've been working on this
for five years and you think you
understand this so well that you can
make me a suggestion he's an American
entrepreneur venture capitalist and
software engineer he's the co-founder
and general partner of the Silicon
Valley venture capital firm andreessen
horowitz he has an estimated net worth
of six hundred million dollars
he's Marc Andreessen and here are his
top ten rules for success the two things
we really zero in on a people are you
know two things they sound simple
they're not being very difficult courage
and genius courage is the one we talk
about a lot because it's the one that
people can learn you know courage
courage which is to say not giving up in
the face of adversity you know just
being absolutely determined to succeed
you know is something that you can you
can like force yourself to do it can be
very painful you can force yourself to
do it the genius part is a little bit
hard to force yourself to do you know
courage without genius might not get you
where you need to go but genius without
courage almost certainly won't and so
we're looking for some kind of magic
combination of genius and courage we
don't believe there's a tension between
products and business we believe there's
a staging which is in this industry you
don't have a business until you have a
product in particular you don't have a
business until you have a product that a
lot of people want we have this concept
we use a term product market fit which
is basically you have a product that the
market wants and you can tell because
the markets pulling product and until
you have that time spent building the
business around the product is pointless
because it's not going to go anywhere
like best case is going to be a zombie
there's a lot of companies are in the
valleys a lot of companies the valley
elsewhere that are you know 25 50 75
people they've got a product nobody
really wants it they sell a few every
quarter and they kind of you got a
living and they go on for year after
year after year after year after year
and they never get anywhere they never
go public they never get bought and
people just basically collect salaries
and that's not that's like not what we
want to do and that's not what's super
you know super high potential
entrepreneurs want to do so what we
basically say is if you want to build a
big success you've got to nail the
product you got it like it's got to be a
killer product it's got to be something
that has product market fit when you
have product market fit then you build a
company around it right so then you
build a sales force then you start doing
marketing and then you start doing
business deals then you start expanding
international and you do all this other
stuff and it's at that point where you
start to apply a lot of capital and you
build a big board and you start hiring
executives and doing all this stuff but
a full executive team with a sales force
and all that stuff before you have the
killer product is a complete waste of
time
entrepreneurs are often uniquely bad at
wrapping their heads around timing
because entrepreneurs by definition are
highly optimistic people because you
have to because you're starting a
company and that you have to be highly
optimistic if you're if you're going to
set up and do that and you're probably
so optimistic that you're probably too
aggressive on timing you probably assume
that something is going to happen in the
market faster than it's actually going
to and so sometimes what you see happen
see you see the Friendster myspace
Facebook scenario you see that happen a
lot you see a company fail and then
another company with the exact same idea
at six years later and it's a huge
success and it's just flat out simply
timing and I don't know what to say you
know well I don't know in general what
to say about that in the specifics
there's a lot of specific things that I
think you do to try to address that you
try to keep your burn rate low we try to
give yourself run away for the market to
develop you know you try to correct for
the fact you're probably being too
optimistic but I think in practice
that's a lot of luck the entrepreneur
with the idea at the right time is going
to look like a genius the entrepreneur
with the right idea the wrong time is
gonna look like a [ __ ] and it's really
hard it's not the preneur to tell the
difference and by the way right there's
always been this kind of thing in
Silicon Valley of like you know sort of
this I call the failure fetish right
failure is good right failures you tell
you guys are probably all have been
taught this heard about this for a lot
of people like failure is a wonderful
thing failure teaches you all this stuff
and it's great to fail a lot like and we
don't like buy any of that we think
that's all complete complete nonsense we
think failure sucks we think failure is
a terribly terribly depressing thing to
go through
we think success on the other hand is
wonderful.i
you know you wouldn't think that this is
something you have to actually say out
loud but we do find it to be clarifying
when we point it out and so we are
strongly biased towards people who are
so determined to succeed that they just
they never give up they never quit and I
think that is a huge part of it that's
something we really look deep we look
try to look deeply for we and you know
yet that's the kind of thing that's not
listed on a resume right that's
something that has to be deep in
somebody's fundamentally deep in
somebody's character and you have to see
it in their backgrounds new companies
generally shouldn't exist existing
companies are usually pretty good at
what they do and so for a new company to
exist it not only has to like you know
come into going to business some bring a
product to market but it has to bring a
product to market that's so much better
than what already exists that it punches
through the sort of status quo and you
know most customers in most markets are
pretty happy buying from the current
suppliers and so there has to be a real
kind of edge on the thing I really for
that I'm either a technology change
usually a technology change or an
economic change which are often the same
thing the single best piece of advice
I've ever heard I heard the other day
watching Steve Martin the comedian on
Charlie Rose and Steve Martin for I'm
sure everybody in room knows who Steve
Martin is but he's one of our successful
comedians of the last you know 30 years
across many different media across
television and movies and books and
everything he's been tremendously
successful and he recently wrote a book
about it's actually really funny because
it's it's it's a book about how he
became successful and it's not even a
funny book I mean it's Steve Martin so
it's a little bit funny but it's not
like a comedy book he actually sat down
and wrote a book of like how I did it in
a particular writing comedy comedies a
little bit like like startups and that
there are a few comedians like Jerry
Seinfeld or Steve Martin that are like
hugely successful and then there's like
you know for every one of those there's
10,000 others you know we're still
playing nightclubs you know in very
small towns so there's there's a huge
dispersion from the big winners to
large number of people who work in
working fully hard who don't get there
and he boiled it down to something I
think was incredibly insightful obvious
but insightful is you know he said the
piece of young comedians always come to
me and they say well you know how do i
how do I be like you ought to be
successful like you and he said you know
they're always looking for like how do I
get an agent or how do I get booked or
how do I get on The Tonight Show or how
do I get it you know get a movie role
and he said you know the real answer is
be so good that they can't ignore you
and it turns out that you know he just
and this is what his book talks about is
he applied himself with a level of
discipline at being an amazing comedian
and it's really funny right Steve
Martin's a great illustration of this
because Steve Martin on stage is
incredibly silly and he's got the banjo
he's got the if he watches footage from
the 70s when he was when he was
something coming you know he's got the
arrow through his head he's like you
know dancing around he's he's doing all
this crazy stuff and it looks like he's
just clowning but the level of
discipline and rigor and practice that
he put into it you know was astonishing
over over a decade long period and then
you know after a decade of hard work was
a sudden overnight success but the key
point there being be so good that they
can't ignore you if there's a form like
this in a group like this and and and
and efforts like like this and my blog
and all these things you know we we we
all talk a lot about the mechanics of
how do you hire people or how do you
raise money or how do you do this or how
do you do that or how do you sell your
company and a lot of that it's important
stuff but a lot of it is window dressing
around the core sort of proposition of
the core problem which is how to be so
good that they can't ignore you and in a
start-up a lot of that has to do with
have an idea that so that they can't
ignore you and you know the best idea
having
the right idea and having at the right
time of being able to execute on it is
99% of it and the rest the rest of the
stuff will be all talked about and I
talk about all the time is all kind of
add-on ancillary to that there are no
silver bullets there are only LED
bullets
there's this there's this temptation you
especially going to get into crisis when
you get into a real problem there's this
temptation to think there must be a
magic answer like there must be some
stroke of genius you know there it's all
mostly it's like what you I don't know
if people watch the new Sherlock Holmes
you know TV series which I just love
it's like you know Sherlock is going to
hat you know no matter how dire it gets
no matter how like evil Moriarty is sure
likes going to have that stroke of
genius it's going to save the day and
there's this really strong tendency to
kind of think that that that's out there
and we see a lot of entrepreneurs they
kind of cycle through different silver
bullets and then they don't work and
they don't work and they don't work
Ben's point is always it's probably the
answer is probably in firing a whole
bunch of lead bullets and so the answer
probably is you know the engineer is
working you know later at night for you
know six months and you know getting the
next version of the product out and the
answer is probably for you know the
sales reps to go call on twice as many
customers and try to close some more
deals and the answer is probably to you
know your stock prices low you know go
find the investors who are willing to
invest when you're trading in half the
cash because it turns out they actually
do exist and then your stock goes up a
little bit people start to regain
confidence and so I would say I've you
know I've certainly come around to that
point of view a lot and so when we work
with entrepreneurs we often have very
similar advice because it's kind of
it'll be tempered through the very
practical realities of what you have to
do to get through a situation like that
I think our company systematically are
too weak on helping people evolve in
their careers and develop new skills and
I think that same thing is true across
the entire economy and you almost can't
be too good at it
the classic example the valley right now
is everybody needs mobile everybody's
iOS programmers and so everybody's out
trying to recruit the same it feels like
there's only 3,000 like iOS programmers
in the valley and everybody's trying to
quit them all it's like what you've got
like you know you've got a lot of these
companies you've got Java programmers
you've got PHP programmers and you've
got web programmers it's like you know
take you know four months and and we
actually there's a training company we
work with called big nerd ranch and
they're spectacular they literally are
like it's a big nerd ranch it's like
where you send you send people off and
they train them out of the iOS
programmers at the big nerd ranch
and yeah everybody's ready better though
yeah he's pointing to somebody who's
been there and so you know train people
up on how to do these things we have
another company called Udacity that does
this kind of training now online it is
rolling out all these tracks to be able
to train people how to do mobile
development or how to train people how
to do a data science and so I think that
the development career path skills
training is going to be such a more
fundamental part of how the economy
works and I think it has to be because
right today we're all hiring mobile
developers you know three years from now
we're all going to need to hire you know
neural implant developers or whatever
it's going to be I love it and we're
gonna and we're gonna have that exact
same problem again how do you as you
grow the startup to be a lot bigger
prevent mediocrity from creeping in
right so I love this question I love
because I think there's a there's
actually a way to think about this as a
from a system standpoint so me my
business partner my last company Ben
Horowitz kind of a term he calls the the
law of crappy people and we have focused
on a lot of my last company we focus on
my current company and basically a lot
of crappy people it's basically a
derivation of the concept that a people
hire a people and B people hire see
people which is kind of a cliche and
everybody kind of knows that but a lot
of crappy people kicks in as you grow
and with a lot of crafty people really
is is that the capabilities or the
confidence at of the people at any level
in your company as you grow are going to
degrade to the worst person at that
level in your company and so your your
vice presidents over time are all going
to be as bad as your worst vice
president your director is over time
we're all going to be as bad as your
worst director your engineers over time
are all going to be as bad as your worst
engineer and the reason is because the
way that hiring decisions get made and
the way that promotion decisions get
made inside a company is within
reference to the people who are already
there and so I'm a manager I want Joe to
get promoted from engineers engineer to
senior engineer I my argument is he's a
really good engineer
the other you know executives who are
battling for promotions for their people
say well he's not that good and then I
say well he's at least as good as you
know Bob you know who's your guy who is
a senior engineer and you know you're
like okay yeah well yeah I guess that's
true Bob isn't that great Bob Business
senior engineer so clearly Jo should
also be a senior engineer and before you
know it all your senior engineers are as
bad as Bob and it's it's it's it's
absolutely astonishing it's absolutely
astonishing to watch because it
basically degrades if somebody
significantly better than the worst
person they get promoted and when new
people get hired you know they get they
get hired in reference to the worst
person to level so it's basically on a
level by level basis and you basically
need to just beat it back with a stick I
mean you need to be like so determined
to not have the stance with their term
that people use the soft bigotry of low
expectations you need to be absolutely
determined to have your definition of
good not be the average of the people we
have in the company or the person who
was accidentally promoted to a certain
level who really shouldn't invent now
that he is that's the definition of the
level because because he's now part of
it and you just need to absolutely beat
it back with a stick and one of the
heuristics I think you can use to beat
it back is to ask yourself the question
on every hire and every promotion is are
you are you raising the average because
you probably either if you're hiring
somebody or promoting somebody you're
either going to be raising the average
at that level or for that role in the
company or you're going to be lowering
the average and if you're continuously
raising the average which is very hard
to do then you're going to defeat the
law cracking people but if you're not
super focused and super determined on
that then it will inevitably degrade
really bright founders with these really
radical ideas tend to go through with a
call the idea may so they tend to have
worked for years working their way
through the idea to try to figure out
how to get from kind of the initial
crazy starting point to at the end
something that will actually work in the
real world and the really great
entrepreneurs can walk you through the
idea maze and make you understand the
flow of thinking that got got them to
the point where they actually came out
the other end with what is a great idea
and what's interesting about that is
those are generally not there's this
kind of you know theory in venture
capital you want to back coachable
entrepreneurs the entrepreneurs who
really have the radical ideas are
generally not only not coachable
they generally react with hostility to
being coached and so one of the things
we test for is you know basically say
well you know have you thought about
doing it this other way and what we're
not looking for is the oh that's a great
idea what we are looking for is the
stare that's just like you idiot right
you [ __ ] you've been sitting here
listening that you know this is them
talking to me you've been sitting here
listening to me for twenty minutes and
I've been working on this for five years
and you think you understand this so
well that you can make me a suggestion
and not only are you an idiot for
thinking you can do that but I will now
explain to you in detail why you're that
big of an idiot we love those like those
are fantastic those are outstanding and
so and it goes right back to the
combination a genius encouraged I was
talking about and so in particular I
mean it's part it's in the words but
also part of its just the look on the
face we love that look
it's like caviar thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because
FB GM 247 asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what your marks
top ten rules hit you the hardest is
going to have the biggest impact on your
business and why leave in the comments
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon